guten tag meine damen und herren wenn
darunter nicola maßnahmen wirken und
zwar nicht nur gegen kugelt 19
wir sehen in der gesamten bevölkerung
viel weniger infektionskrankheiten als
sonst hat reduktion das abstandhalten
dass masse getragen die händehygiene und
das lüften verhindert eben auch dass wir
uns mit anderen erregern anstecken und
das ist gerade in diesen pandemie zeit
natürlich ein echter pluspunkt
arztpraxen und krankenhäuser zu
entlasten
zusätzlich obendrauf kommen das
wichtigste beispiel inter weiß ja so
wenig grippefälle wie möglich zu haben
also viele grippewelle wie möglich
verhindern und das ist uns bislang sehr
gut gelungen ich sage bislang weil wir
natürlich alle nie in die zukunft
schauen können normalerweise haben wir
zu beginn eines jeden jahres immer eine
grippewelle die fällt unterschiedlich
schwer aus aber normalerweise bekommen
wir dann jede woche mehrere tausend oder
sogar mehrere zehntausend fälle
übermittelt und tausende menschen müssen
im krankenhaus behandelt werden
im moment sehen wir aber nur 20 bis 30
grippe fälle pro woche das sind so
wenige wie sonst nur im sommer und in
dieser saison gab es auch bislang erst
150 schwere fälle im krankenhaus die
grippewelle ist alte bislang
ausgeblieben übrigens weltweit und das
ist auch ein großartiger erfolg
ähnlich sieht es auch bei vielen anderen
akuten atemwegserkrankungen aus also bei
den erkältungen anfang februar 2020 also
im letzten jahr gab es etwa 5,6
millionen akute atemwegserkrankungen in
deutschland pro woche anfang februar
diesen jahres anfang für über 20 21 sind
es gerade einmal circa 900.000 also 4,7
millionen weniger
wir sehen auch viel weniger
durchfallerkrankungen viel weniger
masernfälle für 2020 sind nur 75 masern
fälle übermittelt worden an das robert
koch institut
sonst sind es mehrere hundert muss
manchmal auch mehrere tausend heute wird
uns dazu einen artikel im
epidemiologischen bulletin
veröffentlicht den sie dann auch unsere
website www.iaa.de finden
bei coop setzt sich der trend im
infektionsgeschehen weiter fort
erfreulicherweise gehen die fallzahlen
insgesamt zurück die bundes heute sieben
tages inzidenz liegt aktuell bei 62
und sie geht regional natürlich sehr
unterschiedlich voran
auf vielen intensivstation stabilisiert
sich die situation
sie ist aber immer noch angespannt und
leider sterben immer noch sehr viele
menschen im zusammenhang mit 19
insgesamt haben wir nun in deutschland
ans robert koch-institut 64.000 191
fälle übermittelt worden
ein verstorbenen aber trotzdem sind wir
alles in allem auf einem guten weg wir
wissen auch dass einige saß kopf zwei
varianten einen boost erhalten haben
dass sie ansteckender geworden sind und
dass sie sich auch in deutschland
ausbreitet
wir hatten ja letzte woche erste
ergebnisse vorgestellt wonach eine der
varianten und zwar diese variante b 11 7
die zunächst im vereinigten königreich
nachgewiesen wurde
einen anteil von etwa sechs prozent der
untersuchten proben ausgemacht hat und
in dieser woche wird diese erhebung in
den laboren noch einmal wiederholt so
dass wir dann in der nächste woche den
trend nochmals genauer anschauen und
beschreiben können aber wir gehen
natürlich davon aus dass es so wie auch
in anderen ländern in europa der fall
sein wird diese varianten zunehmen
werden deshalb auch noch meine bitte
verhindern wir doch alle wenn immer
möglich ansteckungen wir müssen die
ausbreitung der varianten zumindest
verlangsamt und wir müssen verhindern
dass neue besorgniserregende varianten
entstehen
wir alle können die virus ausbreitung
damit aktiv verhindern
das gelingt uns wenn wir alle aktiv so
viele ansteckungen wie möglich
verhindern jede infektion meine damen
und herren jede ist eine zu viel
wir müssen taten befragen um zu sehen
dass die maßnahmen wirken wir sehen
den daten dass unsere anstrengungen die
kontakt reduktion und das einhalten der
rh + l regeln also das lüften den
abstand halten hygiene anhalten masken
tragen dass diese maßnahmen wirken
sie würden gegen kugelt 19 und sie
wirken auch gegen viele andere
ansteckende krankheiten geben wir all
diesen krankheiten weiterhin keine
chance
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren